what's going on you guys x-men Dark
Phoenix has been unleashed upon theaters
that is bringing the Fox chapter of
x-men to a close what do we think about
the journey x-men have taken from the
animated series through the movies where
will it go now that it's potentially
part of the MCU we're about to break
that down with an amazing panel of
experts first off we have the creators
and writers of the x-men animated series
Erik and Julia Lee Walt thank you for
being here thank you so much for having
us here my goodness this panel is just
this is an amazing panel I have to say
that again and again he's I'm excited to
break down the stuff with these folks
right over here he's the screenwriter of
Thor x-men first class and currently on
Netflix check out rim of the world
sextants
and welcome to the party and this
gentleman he is an esteemed nerd you
know from Nerdist hype RPG DC daily and
El Rey nation hector navarro thanks
everybody
Wow so this is a great panel so I think
everybody here digs the x-men a little
bit yeah yeah I've had that theme song
stuck in my head for most of my life
yeah yeah yeah absolutely let's get
let's get in the Wayback Machine let's
talk about one of the first and best
incarnations of x-men that we've seen
the animated series I just my
observation is is I think that your
series in some of the other some of the
other animated superhero shows of that
time we're kind of the secret parents of
the comic book movie Renaissance
absolutely 100% 100% because literally a
whole generation of kids they weren't
reading comic books because comic books
were already they weren't $0.15 anymore
they were already too expensive and they
weren't in supermarkets the way they
used to be their introduction to these
characters was via your show and by the
time they hit their teenage years and
young adulthood that was when the movie
started started started appearing and
they were primed to become fans so shows
like yours don't get nearly enough
credit for kind of paving the way for
kind of paving the way for this this
cultural moment that we're in
yeah I said it before we started the
Marvel animated universe and
specifically x-men the animated series
they had to walk so that the movies
could run there were stuff that I might
not have picked up on as a kid watching
the show but going back and re watching
it as an adult I am blown away at how
much of this show is about the
persecution of different people the
other ring the scapegoating the real
core themes of what makes the x-men
you know Universal those concepts of
this person's born different therefore
we're going to put them in internment
camps we're going to round them up we're
going to all of that stuff powers and
all the flashy stuff aside that stuff
was great but that I was so surprised
how much of that made it into the show
and you guys before we started shooting
we're telling me Dave they let us pretty
much we're flying under two radars you
know the Marvel and the Fox radar
because they were saying push it push it
push it so the show had so much of that
that's a great point so that yet the
subtext and the actual text of the the
social issues and what x-men says about
humanity how much tell us how that
affected your writing there were two
main themes that we could figure out in
the first twenty years of the books and
one of them was the x-men fighting
against evil mutants and that was just
kind of more of a of a live wrestling
struggle or a gladiator you know who's
gonna be who which is fun and fantastic
and the things kids love but the other
thing was the sense of exclusion and you
know Malcolm X versus Martin Luther King
in terms of you know our we have a
minority do you want to try to integrate
do you want to try to have you know
separate nation how do you deal with
people's differences and that seemed to
be much more the more intriguing as far
as storytelling went so we specifically
consciously focused on that was okay
well who's who we'll set this up best
and the Sentinels for two or three
reasons were the perfect villain for the
first series because they're like this
walking embodiment of human intolerance
towards mutants they were they were lot
they were the they were the Gestapo
coming out to round up the Jews and at
the same time they're something we could
blow up yes yeah we couldn't hit someone
in the face you couldn't see blood you
couldn't stab anybody
there'll be these huge fights among
these incredibly powerful beings and
that's one of the frustrations of
children's television is that if if that
was realistic there'd be a lot of harm
going on well you can't show it well you
can show it to robots so that way all
these frustrations of these people could
be taken out on those sentinels in the
pilot episode when Wolverine comes off
the the jet and and punches Cyclops in
the stomach for presumably leaving Worf
behind that was a week to get that
permission to allow a human to punch
another human in the stomach and it
never happened again in the show yeah I
was hoping you'd speak to that a little
that that sometimes the straitjacket of
having to produce things for kids or
something like that forces you do you
find that there are places where it
forced you to be more creative
absolutely there's there's a pace and an
intensity to our show that if we've been
allowed to use casual violence which we
weren't we would we wouldn't have pushed
ourselves that hard to make it as
intense emotionally as we did because we
need to do that because we couldn't show
sex we couldn't show most violence so we
had to make it character stuff that
you're perfectly right the the limits
focused us and it was it ended up being
helpful and as Hector and Zak so
eloquently pointed out your show is it
stands as a true precursor and the the
seeds that seeded the clouds for these
films for what we have today so let's
start with the first trilogy x-men came
out in 2000 was a box office success
ninth highest grossing movie of 2002 me
about your thoughts on that film how it
resonated and how you saw it compared to
the show
III I know you were mentioning earlier
Zach that sort of being the perfect
target demographic I was growing up on
the show so now I'm in my like early
teens and the movie start coming out and
I will never forget when it opens up on
the boots walking through the mud in the
Holocaust the magneto storyline which
going from the show learning about the
comic books and learning about that
character I think I was still as a young
person blown away that this movie which
was a pg-13
action four-quadrant you know
blockbuster movie for everybody and this
was only like a couple years after I had
learned about World War 2 and the
Holocaust in school I go to see that
real world parallel put into this big
fantasy thing with a bunch of
superheroes so the first movie I think
you know we were talking about the
limitations the budgetary limitations
the the fact that it was focused as a
character piece I think was so smart so
successful and introduced the the sort
of larger world even though it did poke
fun at the yellow spandex actually go up
side what would you prefer yellow
spandex maybe in retrospect didn't have
to do that didn't have to be that
embarrassed about making an x-men movie
but I think overall all of the decisions
that they made were really really smart
to be able to introduce these characters
and these concepts to a worldwide
audience that's really funny that you
say that because starting off in the
Holocaust like that it's like you have
the specter of like Schindler's List in
that IND is just absolutely few years
prior Private Ryan and absolutely yeah
for sure how did you guys feel about the
film and well relieved for one thing
because they got so much of it right I
mean that's going into it after having
lived with these characters for five
years and thinking that we know them as
well as anybody does and having kind of
a familial interest in them that you
know there were think there were a few
things we would have done differently I
think I think the underserved the women
in in our show we tried to highlight how
strong storm and rogue were and Jean
Grey and how big a part they were of
this world and I don't think Halle Berry
had anything to do in the FIR in the
first week it was it was very satisfying
to see that the team they chose pretty
much reflected the team that you chose
going into what became it and we kind of
expected it because the screenwriter
spoke to us afterwards and we'd seen it
in print that that they hadn't gone back
to the comics that their reference point
was our show absolutely that they said
they didn't have to economy both they'd
just watch this and was it Hugh Jackman
evidently went up to Cal dot or
Wolverine said I'm so tired of listening
to your voice
I will say that the concept of a
superhero genre which we're talking
about now
that didn't exist prior to I say 2000
with x-men the movie coming out
you had Batman's you had Superman's and
those but everyone get a couple of them
they'd fade out a couple they'd fade out
but now what the superhero is a genre
now it is a category of film like
westerns like musicals like film noir
and I think if I give all credit to it
and after 90 I was gonna say and it
needed that after 1997 I believe it was
Batman and Robin
I think everyone a lot of people were
like I think the comic-book movie is
kind of done and then the next I think
it was 98 blade came out and I was like
oh maybe there's a little life in there
yet and then it was in them but then to
me it was that one-two punch of x-men
and then the Raimi spider-man that was
like you know both of them doing
blockbuster business that really paved
the way for for what we're in now and
speaking of a blockbuster business x2
x-men United was a huge movie as well
four hundred seven million worldwide and
a lot of fans feel this is the best of
the x-men films with yeah well because
again it's so funny that everything we'd
be talking about it went back to the
mutant versus human they brought in
William Stryker let's explore the
backstory of Wolverine a little bit
because he was such a fascinating
character and Hugh Jackman was the
breakout star the first movie
we'll be watching but to bring it back
to that human versus mutant fight I
think makes that one one of the
strongest entries and the really
exciting thing is a comic book fan was
to see the Phoenix in the water at the
end of it like of x-men 2 was so except
with such a great way to end that movie
because like oh no fin mechanic yeah
it's like chemical Jensen died couldn't
they have used a bunch of mutant powers
too no she died oh well and then you see
the thing and you're like oh the next
one's gonna be great and then it wasn't
so great but yeah okay so x2 beloved x3
yeah people the last down you know what
scene did it for me that just made me
realize wow the people making this have
no field for the characters that scene
where magneto sends the almost all
mutants of color forward it's like
they've spent two movies and 30 years of
comic books describing how or showing
how magneto loves the mutants and he's
all about protecting the mutants and
then he's going to send them out in a
human wave attack like that's
operational no yeah that like that is
I'm sorry that that ain't Megan that
ain't magneto
yeah and they both Xavier are always
appealing to mutants to follow them and
you can't ask people to follow you if
you just throw them away in a war and I
think our son left up in the middle of
the of expertise you say Geoffrey
Australian um there were certain things
I think my memory of it because it's a
very vague now but it's just it was kind
of - gee I'm packed with oh and history
for people bursting through buildings
and to spectacle - full of people then
not focused on the story and and missing
very important character points and and
then when you you know when you sell the
movie as we are going to knock over the
status quo and change everything and the
last two coda scenes of the movie are
Xavier still alive yes and oh maybe
maybe magneto hasn't lost his powers
after all that's like okay then
what did I just what did I just see for
the last hour and a half who cheats -
double - yeah that's that's that's in TV
writing we always use just you know can
we buy it back and it's like well if you
buy it back why did you sell it to begin
with we kind of hit the first trilogy
let's talk about the spin-offs and then
we'll move on to the later x-men films
including Zach's so you'd mention
Wolverine that has been hit and miss
affair though Waldo Wolverine yes yes
okay so the first one was roaring that
was a bit uneven
we had Wolverine we had Sabretooth we
and we great cast yeah we had Deadpool
Deadpool yeah how did we feel about this
film overall great cast yeah I think I
mean it's a bummer because even the
x-men films that I don't love but I
really like I'll watch them own over
again I think I've only seen x-men
origins Wolverine one time I think x-men
origins Wolverine is it I think the best
example of the sort of the the cliched
problems I think in Hollywood not really
working on that side of the industry of
the too many cooks in the kitchen that
kind of you know missing missed
opportunities all of that stuff is all
in that film there's this thing that
Hollywood does which is take a director
who did a small movie and immediately
give them 150 million dollars and Gavin
hood is a really talented director I've
seen the South African film that he made
that got him that got him the Wolverine
movie it's it's very good but directing
a hundred and fifty million dollar movie
is a completely different skill set it's
largely traffic management and making
the studio executives not feel not feel
nervous when they show up on set and
wonder where all of their all of their
money is going and it just it felt like
he was you know like he needed another
film another maybe medium sized film
like Chris Nolan got so did the somewhat
under performance of x-men origins
Wolverine pull the rug out from under
seemingly a series of
Cement origins blank character films it
did and it didn't
there were several x-men origins
spin-off movies and development that did
get killed kind of like these Star Wars
ones have have been but one of them was
a script called AI magneto that was
Sheldon Turner and then rewritten by
David Goyer in scenes of which ended up
getting folded into x-men first class
there were that's why Sheldon Turner has
shared story credit on x-men first class
over the vehement opposition of some of
the other of some of the other some of
the other parties is that the the Fox
executives were saying we're finding
pieces of that film and saying well we
like this scene and we like this scene
so incorporate into the final movie the
auschwitz opening of x-men first class
where we go back to the first movie but
then pull back the curtain and see that
there is a villain a mutant villain
watching the whole thing who's like a
Mengele figure that was in there that
was in the magneto script even the line
piece was never an option and between in
the line between rage and serenity those
were both in the gore draft of of the
magneto scripted Nazi hunting when he
goes to Argentina and hunt some Nazis
know that was actually in a draft by
Jaime Moss of he was the writer on x-men
first class before us that was the one
scene that he did that you know we we
largely started over again but like that
scene was so good that we we were like
okay we're using this very cool but I
just want to talk about a couple more
the spin-off so the Wolverine we're yeah
Hugh Jackman went to Japan and a lot of
elements of samurai films in this movie
thoughts on the watering I think James
Mangold did a wonderful job with it and
I think it was such a great proof of and
I kind of heard this after the fact of
mangled bring in that movie after it had
come out to the studio and going hey you
know what if the next go around if you
kind of let me even do more it can be
better and then we ended up getting
Logan and so I think so many people have
talked about the two-thirds of that
movie being so
solid and maybe a third of it maybe not
working as much maybe having some of
that that Hollywood movie studio
influenced up well we got to have a big
metal bad guy we got to have that those
kinds of things that that I think can be
forgiven because the rest of the film of
of just you Jackman and a wonderful cast
of Japanese actors doing some really
great dramatic stuff you see you on your
back there's blood everywhere I think
you can forgive the very kind of cliched
superhero Hollywood movie stuff because
the rest of that stuff is so solid
absolutely I mean a grounded genre movie
yeah compared to definitely just fire of
the first origin yeah as much of a
cliche as it is to take away someone's
powers it really works in there because
all of the sudden this guy is vulnerable
in a way that he's never been before and
it's the you know it's kind of we
actually pitched on that movie at one
point before we didn't end up getting it
but but the you know when when james
mangold was telling us the concept we
really sparked to it because it
fundamentally it was like a guy who has
lived too long and wants to die but
can't meets a character who is filled
with life and wants to live but whose
life is running at running out and how
those and and that's just a great
elemental elemental conflict so after
that we speaking of just a departure the
Deadpool films brought a whole new
element and character and Sensibility
were you surprised or throw us out to
everybody to about the success and how
well this movie translated yes and no as
a comic book fan I wasn't surprised
because I was in the same corner that
Ryan Reynolds was in being such a fan of
the character yeah it was in the corner
of you know Ryan Reynolds going no you
guys don't understand comic book fans
have been telling me about this guy for
a long long time I know that I cannot
get out of the park I know what this
character can bring to not just the
x-men franchise but to this genre in
general if we're allowed to be full-on
Deadpool and don't worry about some of
that other stuff and so on that side I
was not surprised at at the movie
successfully pulling that off I think it
had all the right elements on the other
side I'm completely blown away that
movie even came out and did so well like
I'm
so blown away that it was as rated-r as
it was I mean talk about a tonal shift
this was this was just insane here's the
thing though that movie came along at
exactly the right point in the superhero
movie cycle to be appreciated if that
moot if the exact same movie had come
out in 2005 or even 2009 or 2010 I don't
think it would have been nearly as much
of a success because the audience hadn't
have had 15 years of those tropes in
cliches in some cases for Deadpool to
come along and make fun of super ER
landing you know that's really hard on
your knees you know it's one of the
reasons why I think the old version of
the tick never did as well as it should
the audience wasn't familiar enough the
audience wasn't familiar enough with
those tropes to realize what was being
made fun of yeah this was a product of X
number of years of superhero film
exactly though though there's the in I'm
interested in what you both think about
this the slighest thing to me about the
first deadpool movie is for about 15
minutes it's a full-on x-men movie but
like old-school like comic book acts
more like the comic book x-men and the
animated x-men than any of the movies
have been and it totally works the whole
like colossus and negasonic teenage
warhead is the you know this the trainee
and the and the teacher like that just
it feels like it straight out of the
comic books absolutely yeah thoughts um
well and somehow to their credit Marvel
has been able to keep making the
superhero genre film but they are such
variation in there there's the Western
with Logan there's you know the the dark
r-rated comedy with Deadpool it's not
just a superhero movie they have they
come up with all these different
variations absolutely right that that
now there was enough stuff to refer to
and and also I think if it had been the
third or fourth movie people would
wonder why you know might have been
uncomfortable with it but there's God so
it becomes so much part of the culture
that it was time to this issue and and
he he he was allowed to make it so
different yeah and that was and we just
came out of the theater
exhilarated saying we weren't expecting
this so we got a very different kind of
r-rated x-men movie with Logan and yeah
how did that film resonate well we
actually were able to to spend some time
with with Len lien before he just before
he passed and he he was able to see it
the guy that created and and and really
loved it and then and talked talked
about how how true it was to the
character and what a great way to go out
I I personally I find the last little
bit like the third act a little bit a
little bit sloppy in terms of okay we're
getting up to the mountains and we're
gonna resolve this I found that a little
bit awkward but 90% of the movie it's
just it's just spot-on and they got the
mood and talked about a way to to ground
and make human the these guys lives and
and we've known Wolverines 110 he's seen
too much he's where we kept on talking
about when we were doing the show in the
90s he's world weary people got tired of
hearing that but he that movie was as
world-weary as you could get and you
really pulled for them and it was
intricately beautifully done bringing
that girl bring the girl in yeah yeah
great way to in a lot of ways sort of
end that chapter of the x-men film
series with Patrick Stewart new Jackman
just delivering I think their best
performances as those characters up to
that point okay so we talked about the
original trilogy we talked about some of
the spin-offs now the the new x-men saga
we had already touched upon a bit but
yeah please regale us with stories from
first class I mean I mean if you know if
you know professional sports at all Fox
very much was going into first class as
a franchise rebuilding year it was they
they recognized that that even though
those last two movies have made a lot of
money that they maybe hadn't been
beloved and it was okay we've got a new
cast we're going back to the or we're
going back to the origins in the 1960s
and and this is a chance to this is a
chance to start fresh again and you know
we just you know we had 10 days to write
the first draft of the script because in
typical fox fashion they had a release
date and no script and they wanted to
get a you know they wanted to get a hot
director onto it and they were they were
already circling Matthew Vaughn at that
point and they needed a script good
enough to get him onto and so they set
us loose and you know the ten days later
and no sleep they we managed to get
agreeing that we managed to get a green
light yeah I mean Matthew Vaughn the
script and then the casting I mean how
do you fill the shoes of Patrick Stewart
and you know Ian McCloud McAvoy and fast
men are so great I was in a there's
construction going on in our house so I
was using so I was writing the script or
you know co-writing the script in a
little office next to my favorite Fox
executive who was in charge of it and he
I was 10 o'clock at night it was like
Zack come in here I want to show you the
the chemistry read we just did with
because they were thinking of a they
were thinking of a couple different guys
for magneto at that point the other one
was the guy they ended up casting in
Abraham Lincoln vampire hunter a really
good actor but they said you know he was
saying like he's like this guy
Fassbender like like some of the
executives think he's too old
thinks think he plays too old next to
McAvoy and we watched the tape and it
was them doing a scene together and and
Fassbender still had this ridiculous
like Daniel day-lewis
yeah and there will be blood mustache
because he was doing the the Freud and
Jung movie with David Cronenberg at the
time but as soon as he opens his mouth
it's like oh my god that's this is a
superstar this is the guy this is this
is the guy and they were so good
together and it's like look drew and
this is important to the characters
Charles grew up in a mansion yeah
Erik grew up in a concentration camp so
if one of them looks a little older than
the other it's kind of it's not the
years it's the mileage yeah he's been
through some stuff and it were like I I
heard
one person when that movie came out said
you know I really liked it except
Fassbender was a little too old like not
one person I mean that I I think if if
we contributed one one thing to that
script and you know there were a lot of
contributors to that script it was the
idea that if you're going to show them
young don't show them as the same people
only younger show them as the people
they were before the events that you see
shaped them into the characters we we
know and love from the from the first
from the first three movies that's why
it was a you know like originally like
the script that we saw you know you
first see Charles what is he doing he's
giving a lecture where he's giving
essentially that speech the opening
speech about mutation from the first
movie and it was okay what if he's not
giving a lecture what if he's giving
that speech but he's using it to pick up
a girl in a bar because he's a callow
he's a he's he's he has the seeds of
greatness but he's still a callow horny
young dude chance Xavier how do you do
Amy Hetrick Romeo is in reference to
euros which I have to say us don't name
one green one blue it's a mutation it's
a very groovy mutation exactly and what
if we show in again and what if we show
Eric where he's an angry young man he's
killing Nazis but he could go either way
there is a chance that he might be one
of our that he might be one of our core
good good guys but you know the tragedy
of that movie is his past and the events
of the movie teach him don't trust
humans I mean I just love that film
x-men first class and it was an amazing
bridge between the future and what had
come before
so yeah x-men Days of Future past we
talked about a soft rebuild hard reboot
with x-men Days of Future past yeah and
a lot of people love this movie some
people are a little bit divisive what
are your thoughts having had the chance
to work on that story back with the
animated series it was like oh I want to
see what they're doing now you know
what's so interesting you guys almost
the same thing in your episodes
Wolverine was gonna go back in time you
had Wolverine about to go back in time
at first and then they say you old old
timer girl this is going yeah it's a
reset Bishop but the idea of a body
going you know Wolverine being the
central instead of Kitty Pryde or
whatever and then the movie did that
yeah I still slightly prefer what we did
with the story as far as it not being
just about that a mystique DNA and I
can't use it why don't you just like
lock her up somewhere and then go shoot
this guy yourself we liked the idea that
Bishop was that there was there was some
terrible problem and that one of the
x-men might be have to be sacrificed and
all the other ones thinking about that
and is their traitor among us and when
we even when we laid out the premise or
market I would have a premise to started
he'd even did it so that it wasn't just
gambit that was just the suspicion
everybody had some suspect just became
too big but have having the suspicion
about somebody you care about a family
member are we gonna have to kill him to
preserve the future was tighter
dramatically for us but all the elements
you're talking about were true it's a
good movie and and just having all these
special people playing the characters it
just was yeah yeah not to mention the
the Quicksilver scene oh that our first
introduction to what how much fun you
can have with Quicksilver they told me
you control metal
hey you know my mom was knew a guy who
could do that okay so after x-men Days
of Future past
x-men apocalypse another x-men film that
was met with a lot of mixed reviews a
little bit uneven what do we think about
Oscar Isaac the apocalypse and that
incarnation of apocalypse I think I
think great cast I think it was a little
bit of a missed opportunity to really to
really bring to the screen of really
really interesting character talking
about immortality talking about you know
apocalypse and Subban or the first one
the very first mutant and I think that
Oscar Isaac loves the character I think
he loves the character because I feel
like he also like watched the show and
like loved apocalypse from that era of
comics and cartoons this but you know
some of those Hollywood creative
decisions you'd be like well we can't
make them blue we got too many blue
people so he'll be kind of purply and
it's like well now all the fans are
gonna rag on the fact that he looks kind
of purply like that's like avenues you
know fans have very long memories we
remember the Power Rangers movie you
can't just do something that looks kind
of similar to that but some really good
stuff in there some great performances
great young actors but but I think you
know is still indicative of the sort of
a little bit of a missed opportunity I
can't say a bad word against Oscar Isaac
the man is amazing but in my heart I
hear John collee Coast who was the voice
talent for us on apocalypse and just
that John collee deep voices and he and
he was because he was so much larger
than life and that's the thing that blew
it up the movie for me the first 1/2
hour I was kind of in it and it because
we we thought when we did the animated
show we needed make sure that he was so
much larger than life other other
villains are little or or dance or
whatever he was just larger-than-life
thing that everybody else you know
slammed against and died the thing
there's a scene where they're just
walking around our Isaac's is five foot
nine there's nothing wrong with that
but they're just walking around in some
some broken-down cityscape and there's
yeah there's three or four there's three
or four x-men and there's
and he's talking to them and chatting
and he's about to you know he's he's
about the size of Jubilee that's not
apocalypse apocalypse gets huge and and
destroy civilizations he doesn't chat
when the movie came out I remember
feeling like it could have been shot
differently to add that scale but then I
think with the success of the character
of Thanos in the most recent Avengers
movies being a CG character and having
that scale I mean he's literally he's
the 12 foot tall guy would you guys have
gone CG and had Oscar Isaac provide the
voice oh sure just I mean just to
maintain something made him different
it's Porsche yeah honestly I wouldn't
have used apocalypse it up at all or I
would have changed it changed it in some
way in my mind that you know aside from
weird structural things the main problem
is just I like movies especially
superhero movies where the villain has
some kind of an emotional connection to
the heroes and you know like Sebastian
Shaw I agree with everything you said oh
but you killed my mother you know like
like that's why you like Sebastian Shaw
as a Ville is a villain and like to see
him you know like like he was much more
like what's his name Steppenwolf and the
Justice League movie it's like you're
just a dude who wants to do some stuff
okay and we just so as we mentioned at
the top Dark Phoenix is now upon us and
yeah I would love to hear some thoughts
it is not breaking any box-office
records I have had this conversation
with some friends recently we're talking
about this we're talking about men and
black international opening to not great
numbers yes and and Zac maybe you can
provide some insight with x-men first
class you mentioned how x-men 3 The Last
Stand x-men origins Wolverine did great
box office but then sort of was thought
of as not being great films did that
affect x-men first class because what
I'm saying is I think Dark Phoenix might
be feeling reeling from a little bit of
people not being stoked about apocalypse
you're only as good as your last movie I
think the French franchise movies are
very much a ref the box office is very
much a referendum on how people felt
about the last one and you're like like
first-class people like that yes people
like that movie didn't didn't do any
more money
at the box office than x-men origins
Wolverine it's just but then people
watched it on video and like it got
people and then the next one did really
well yeah x-men The Last Stand great box
office because in my mind because people
loved x2 and were and wanted to see more
of you know wanted to see more of those
characters so yeah I think I think dark
phoenix ran into the perfect storm of
perception that it was a troubled
production underwhelming underwhelming
feelings about the last movie and the
fact that we're in the summer right now
and and we're in this new box office
environment where if a movie isn't a
must-see people are waiting for video
people are only rolling out for the
must-sees because there's so many other
entertainment options now I was gonna
say I'm wondering too there seem to be
with the success of the Iron Man and
Avengers and that whole guardians of the
galaxy and the culmination of it as a
film go or it's like okay they're had in
a certain direction and I'm gonna go
along for the ride
whereas with Dark Phoenix I kind of had
the feeling I'm not sure where they
thought they had set this up that this
was going to be the payoff right just as
a fan of the thing yeah part of the
problem for us was I think Marvel create
a little of this early they weren't
quite sure what the Phoenix was it's
inside gene it's inside gene for a few
years in the comics and that for you
know a few issues
oh hi Phoenix you know you want some
coffee the Phoenix was not this super
being that's inhabiting someone you love
she just kind of turned into Phoenix and
they didn't quite know what to do with
her and it just seemed all in the movies
just like well she's overheated well we
we talked about Days of Future past
let's just talk about the future
great transition there how are you guys
so yeah where do you see them going what
do you want to see what's the right move
cuz it's you don't just plop them in
there I would love for a wonderful new
actor to be found to play Wolverine
years from now I'd love for Wolverine to
interact with Hulk and some of them
because that's I love that side of the
Wolverine storyline is when he gets
interact with some of those characters
but I would love for them to find a and
I love Hugh Jackman an actor who was not
classically handsome you want 35
year-old Bob Hoskins yes is like 35
year-old Bob Hoskins is who is is who
the next you know or whoever his
equivalent is is who that you know
because there will be no no Hugh Jackman
comparisons it's like this is a new
interpretation of a classic character
yeah and a lot of people the movie-going
audience they don't realize that the
comic book incarnation of Wolverine is
he's we have five three short hairy and
he says Bob a lot yeah I I saw a
tongue-in-cheek petition online for
Danny DeVito to play Wolverine which
with like what do you think about it's
like I mean he's a little older now yes
again if this was 30 years ago and we
could get Danny DeVito a trainer I would
be like you know what let's try him out
I would like to see that audition tape I
really would but but I would really love
for a new x-men movie to similarly to
x-men first class with a lot of those
characters to be set in the modern day
but have the x-men be predominantly like
16 year olds to go back to those sort of
first comics from the 60s not set it in
the 60s but to have more of a vibe of
like spider-man homecoming where you had
you know young Peter Parker and I my
main thing is I want the movies to feel
like they are about the x-men movies to
feel like they're about the themes of
tolerance and acceptance and to talk
about racism and to talk about prejudice
in these ways and I think that I think
that to have young people be the sort of
voice of those movies to reflect how
young people right now are very
politically active that the young people
that have survived school shootings that
are on Twitter and they're like we're
sick of your crap this is what we
believe I would love to see some of
those feelings and emotions find its way
into a next yeah you mentioned first
class and one of my favorite just
another scene that stands out from first
class is when the young people are
together and like what's your power what
do you got and there is a joy that we
hadn't quite seen in the other films ah
are there other storylines or what would
you like to see infused into the MCU
with x-men well being a gal sitting here
as a female I am not convinced that the
women have been served as well as they
might have been in every movie and I
would lie
to see that honestly looking back at the
xmin image so it wasn't like oh this
girl can fly but that guy can't so we
can't you know it is yeah
it was just no these are the people who
happen make up this team and let's let's
have them go with it and do their thing
I would like to see the women whoever
they happen to be just as integrated as
the guys yeah yeah I'm not sure if we
can do it now since we had the
established the ANA penguin rogue which
was a legitimate rogue I mean see who's
been younger in the books when they see
started but when we go around to cons
and people ask us 9 out of 10 of them
say we so loved how powerful rogue was
and you know as you know especially the
female fan saying you have a sense of
empowerment a sense she and storm made
us feel like we could be superheroes too
and the and the rogue gambit
relationship of all the relationships of
among them what still resonates thirty
years later with the fans that talk to
me here's another thing I want to call -
I'm gonna predict this and I feel like
it's gonna happen in the same way when
Michael Giacchino was hired to score
spider-man homecoming
he used a little bit of the Spider Man
sixties theme yes I guarantee you how
we're gonna hear x-men the animated
series theme in some iteration in the
film's orchestrated like we're gonna
hear it I guarantee you I guarantee you
we're gonna hear it we might even see
two teams running at each other the
friends of humanity running down the
center Manning back a moment
what a beautiful homage that would be
amazing and Zac in that incarnation
because I do love that would they drop
some MCU breadcrumbs in there I mean or
would it yeah I mean I mean I kind of
treated a little bit like that like the
comics and that in that the x-men exist
in the MCU but you kind of want them off
in their own adventures because frankly
there's so many of them they if you put
them together with the rest of the MCU
they kind of over they kind of like like
a hint like in daredevil you just see
the newspaper clippings about the Battle
of New York or something like but yeah
so it's there but it's it's a totally
another III think that a really smart
thing to do again if you focus on a
younger cast of characters is that these
young people have grown up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
used to Iron Man and Thor flying around
and Hulk in Captain America they've
grown up with that so it would not be
the craziest thing for me to have a
Charles Xavier who's very reluctant to
let his students go out and be
superheroes
he wants to shelter his kids he wants to
train them and go look the world is a
prejudice bad place you will be hunted
and feared and the x-men themselves as
16 year-old kids are going no we're
gonna put on costumes
I'm Cyclops I'm Marvel girl I'm Iceman
we're gonna be like The Avengers that's
how we're gonna get the world to treat
us you you make an excellent you make an
excellent point which is which is
mutants appearing in a world where there
have been ten years of superheroes in
the headlines saving people is very
different from you know the the movie in
2000 where you've got Senate hearings of
who are these new mute you know who are
these new care you know humans with
powers appearing and they're yeah what
are they up to
what are they up to Erik Julia please
before we go I would love to hear what
that is right there this is a two-year
labor of love we interviewed all the
cast in the crew the executives the
artists and 450 pages and it's a history
of what it was to like to make this show
from the first day until the last day
and and yeah it's it's a and and it's
and it has comments about all 76 of the
episodes images from all the storyboards
about every one of the episodes and just
it's really fan in fact has has some fan
letters that they sent to us saying oh
you don't understand how much the show
meant to us so there's a there fan
testimonials towards the back of it but
it's just it's a celebration of the the
best job any of us ever had yeah I mean
if you're a fan of x-men the animated
series which I would hope I mean that
seems like a definitive tome yeah well
it's available on Jacob's Brown
media.com and if you look that up if you
buy through them you will get an
autographed copy this or we'll have pre
signed yeah go to them don't do do
Amazon don't you Amazon
the hardback that's been signed and or
see us at a con when we're which will be
an Albuquerque but but yeah now this was
just this is as I say everybody cast
crew artists everybody loved doing this
show and it all comes out in the book
amazing
well Eric Julia so great to have you
here thank you for being such a good
friend of screen junkies and to the
x-men over the years great having you
Hector
thank you for bringing your knowledge
Zach you as well your knowledge
experience fascinating stuff and I want
to thank you for watching what is your
favorite x-men film of all time what's
your favorite incarnation of x-men let
us know in the comments section below
and thanks again for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram bye bye